et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stéphane le foll bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous maire socialiste du
mans ancien ministre on est enfant
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest france bonjour stéphane
bonjour bonjour bonjour on va parler
évidemment de la situation à gauche mais
d'abord les résultats de dimanche soir
emmanuel macron a donc été réélue mais
le rassemblement national n'a jamais été
aussi haut emmanuel macron a tout de
suite dit ce vote oblige il veut
apporter une réponse à la colère qui
s'est exprimée dans les urnes est ce que
voulaient être près vous êtes prêt à
l'aider à apporter cette réponse et art
coûte cette france fracture et oui tous
responsables de ce qui se passe et de
cette fracture tous responsables à
chacun des niveaux où on exerce une
responsabilité et donc chacun doit
retrouver de la mesure dans la manière
dont il fait de la politique ce que je
pense être la meilleure pierre qu'on
peut apporter à l'édifice de la france
aujourd'hui mais
je regarde aussi les choses avec ce qui
a été dit le soir de la victoire
je pense que le discours de manuel mâcon
ce soir là n'était pas à la hauteur
du défi et de l'enjeu que vous pointez
justement aujourd'hui de cette fracture
au niveau de la france
de la france dans le monde avec la
guerre en ukraine et puis une fracture
qui existe aussi à l'échelle européenne
et à l'échelle mondiale tu trouvais que
ce discours était moins un discours
assez satisfait d'être vainqueur
deuxième mandat le seul à avoir réussi
en dehors d'une cohabitation est très
ému mais je n'ai pas senti quelque chose
qui me donne justement des perspectives
à moyen et à long terme par rapport à la
situation
on est beaucoup à celui de 2010 est ce
discours finalement c'est un président
qui nous dit j'ai gagné mais les gens
qui ont voté massivement pour marine le
pen je saurai en tenir compte il avait
dit que ça tourne la même chose et être
sûr pas tout à fait le même compte est
la surprise de son élection en 2017
c'était il y avait une espèce de envie
de réussir une jeunesse qui arrive est
quelqu'un de nouveau là on l'a vu josé
j'avais écrit d'ailleurs carrière s'est
renouvelée qu'est-ce qu'il mentait
leviaux dites vous même
rien n'a été renouvelé c'est bien le
problème la victoire elle est là elle a
été net le malaise reste profond ça
c'est clair est ce que j'avais pressenti
s'est réalisé serre que on n'a pas à
nouveau projet pour la france on a le
même président et avec à peu près les
mêmes éléments de langage la réussite et
l'espoir et la jeunesse en moi donc
quand il dit ce ne sera pas un
quinquennat de continuité vous ne croyez
pas pour vous ça sera 5 ans je sais pas
je regarde simplement tout ce qu'a été
la campagne un jeu quel est le projet ou
à vous ce qu'est ce qu'on santé de ce
projet ou de ce souffle qui aurait été
nécessaire pour un deuxième mandat non
il ya eu un débat sur ben on y reviendra
peut-être sur la retraite à 65 ans et
puis travailler pour toucher le rsa
justement est ce que est ce que par
exemple il faudrait qu'ils amendent son
projet de réforme des retraites pour
donner des gages à alors là on est passé
de 65 ans à 64 potentiellement 65 si
j'ai bien entendu monsieur le maire hier
qui se valent 6 déjà avec le 49-3 à
peine le débat est commencé on revient à
65 ans tout ça reste extrêmement floue
c'était un coup tactique et politique au
premier tour qui consistait à capter la
partie de l'électorat de droite qui
étaient encore disponibles ça a été fait
maintenant l'enjeu c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant je pense que sur la
question des retraites il est inutile
sauf à vouloir compenser par cette
réforme une partie des dépenses qu'on
veut faire ailleurs il utile de faire
cette réforme la réforme qui a été faite
par françois hollande sous le
quinquennat à la fois les 40 annuités
pour les carrières qui permettent à des
gens de partir à 60 ans aujourd'hui un
allongement de la durée de cotisation
régulier
mesurer mais qui permet l'équilbre du
régime c'est ça la bonne formule et
c'est ce qu'il veut faire de prolonger
de quatre mois tous les ans et le départ
à la retraite c'est pas pareil que
l'allongement de la cotisation c'est
quand vous reporter le départ à la
retraite ceux qui ont commencé tôt au
fur et à mesure on dit durée de
cotisation de plus en plus longues quand
vous restez sur la durée de cotisation
vous êtes sur le temps actif et c'est
juste de le faire que de penser
simplement allah dieu
j'ai noté d'ailleurs d'encore il est il
est dit que normalement le point le plus
délicat sera jusqu'en 2030 et après ça
va ce richie gray d'ailleurs je trouve
bizarre que cette réforme en plus si
j'ai bien compris ces quatre mois de
plus donc ça fait six ans on est donc
autour de 2030 cirque au moment où elle
serait terminée j'aurais pas vraiment le
problème des retraites donc je comprends
pas bien sauf à chercher au travers de
ces deux retraits à trouver des
équilibres financiers par rapport à
d'autres mesures et là c'est un autre
sujet alors on pourra en discuter mais
on n'aura pas le temps sur le signal que
d'envoyer est ce que pour vous il doit y
avoir un premier ministre de gauche
est-ce que ça ça semble je sais pas ce
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui soyons je
veux anticiper sur les débats futurs que
vous allez avoir aujourd'hui il ya trois
solutions si j'ai bien compris on se le
pénis on se mélange sony's où on ce
maquereau knees c'est ça le sujet les
trois malfrats blague du 1er tour voilà
bah moi je dis ni l'un ni l'autre ni
l'autre alors quoi du coup mais il ya
par exemple pour ce qui est du
socialisme et des socialistes a
réaffirmé je le disais tout à l'heure
que soit la question de la retraite
c'est pas la ligne de jean luc mélenchon
qui est la bonne on revient à 60 ans et
à 40 annuités alors je sais pas les
évaluations en termes de coûts c'est
entre eux
30 et 60 milliards d'euros comme de
toute façon avec quoi qu'il en coûte on
est on est passé à plus rien ne coûte je
comprends que on peut dire tout et
n'importe quoi socialiste on reste
sérieux on est capable de gouverner on
assume des responsabilités
c'est ça le sujet et on porte un projet
politique de justice mais on le fait en
responsabilité ton voilà ce qu'il faut
faire et je suis pas pour entrer dans
les trois cases que j'ai évoqués ni l'un
ni l'autre ni l'autre conclut on va
parler justement de ce qui se passe du
côté de la gauche évidemment la
prochaine bataille électorale cne ce
sont les législatives une première
discussion aura lieu demain entre le
parti socialiste et les insoumis pour
discuter d'un accord d'un possible
accord pour les législatives eu que vous
êtes favorable non je peux voir une
discussion il faut toujours discuter
mais la question essentielle c'est si on
fait d'accord et jean luc mélenchon a
été très clair c'est pour qu'il devienne
premier ministre donc pour gouverner la
france je reviens à la question que
j'évoquais buteur sur la retraite à 60
ans 40 annuités 50 ce sens pillards
après tout je dis comme claudiane coûte
après on trouvera la position de jean
luc mélenchon souhaite et son de
l'europe qui consiste à dire on va
renégocie tous les traités la france va
devenir un pays non alignés quitter ses
alliés quitter ce qui fait la structure
et la force de la france aujourd'hui
c'est d'elle dans l'europe c'est la
dette des pays doit être achetée par la
banque centrale européenne en petit
sujet quand même pas gagné la faire à
l'échelle européenne mais toutes ces
choses là c'est passablement moi je suis
pour qu'on discute mais quand on veut
gouverner il faut être capable de porter
un projet de gouvernement parce que ces
deux-là franc comtois par jean luc
mélenchon
et il a réussi sa campagne on peut pas
le reprocher ça lui il affirme un projet
il dit d'ailleurs venez et vous rangerez
derrière moi sauf que son projet moi qui
suis socialiste qui est relue encore y'a
pas longtemps les discours de françois
mitterrand en particulier ce magnifique
ce cours qui l'a fait à la fin de son
mandat en 1995 je voulais jospin qui dit
qu'aujourd'hui il faut les rassembler
derrière la france est soumise à oublier
qu'il avait signé le traité d'amsterdam
moi je reste européen mais c'est je ne
peux pas et je reste non seulement
européens puis en plus je reste
décentralisateur la jolie jean luc
mélenchon planification on centralise on
décide d'en haut je re j'ai relu une
partie de son projet on supprime les
métropoles j'aurais d'ailleurs dire à
tous les maires de la fameuse équipe de
france d'anne hidalgo est ce qu'ils sont
d'accord avec la suppression du
métropole
il répondra à aucune question
programmatique on va on va discuter mais
pour pas aboutir un accord ils savent où
il est impossible qu'il ya un agent du
gouvernement entre les socialistes et la
france insoumise tant les divergences
sont grandes mais je vous pose la
question est ce que jean luc mélenchon
renoncera à son programme je crois pas
et est-ce que sociali en responsabilité
je serai capable de gouverner en faisant
ce que je viens de vous dire non alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait semblant
alors mis à gagner quelques députés
alors à mes yeux c'est la politique est
en train de se tuer aujourd'hui et quand
je disais on nous dit il reste le
maquereau 10 le mélenchonisme ou le
lepénisme la gauche et en particulier
les verts qui sont en train de se
mélangent sionisés très bien font un
choix mais derrière l'espoir que peut
donner la gauche c'est d'être capable de
gouverner si les gens considèrent
qu'elle ne peut plus gouverner
l'espoir y en aura plus donc moi je suis
partisan au contraire de réaffirmer unis
de gauche capable de gouverner et
d'assumer et d'assurer une vraie
transition énergie stéphane le foll le
préalable pour être capable de gouverner
c'est d'abord être capable de gagner une
élection est ce que vous pensez que
parti socialiste tout seul peut faire
quelque chose concrètement au lycée mais
le sujet le parti socialiste tout seul
ne peut pas oui il ne peut pas avec le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle on
vous visez quoi vous visez les échanges
futurs bien sûr qu'il faut viser dans la
rue mission la refondation la
reconstruction bien entendu et vous avez
fait qu'est ce que vous dites à olivet
fort qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour les
législatives
enfin quelques projections qui sont
faites aujourd'hui il faut être capable
d'affirmer son identité et le deuxième
point et ça c'est une règle qui s'est
appliqué dans l'histoire ça serait qu'il
y ait au moins un désistement
républicain dire que celui qui à gauche
arrive en tête c'est donc le choix des
électeurs qui est fait celui qui arrive
en tête est bien celui qui est arrivé en
2e se désiste ça ça serait le principe
était impliqué par françois mitterrand
au moment où le parti communiste faisait
plus de 20% et qui s'est toujours pas
toujours été respectée aujourd'hui ces
principes là sont complètement oublié
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs et jean luc
mélenchon on a sa propre responsabilité
puisque la plupart du temps au deuxième
tour quand françois hollande est arrivé
en tête en 2010 il n'a pas appelé à
voter françois ans donc ce principe
républicain doit être mis alors
bien sûr et donc on revient ce principe
donc aux livres se trompe mais bien bah
oui je pense qu'ils se trompent et je
les dis depuis suffisamment longtemps
chemin venu à vos invitations
successives sympathique et ça me fait
toujours plaisir de revenir à public
sénat je les dis suffisamment et je les
dis j'ai prévenu que la stratégie de
l'effacement d'une tragique qui compte
et qui aboutit à l'effacement électorale
et que là se ranger derrière jean-luc
mélenchon
ces dépassements finale politique
passablement électorale en fait la seule
chose qu'il faudrait discuter demain
dans le cadre des accords pour
législatives c'est le retour à ce
principe de désistement républicain
sujet est entrain de ça ça doit être un
principe majeur alors que depuis
quelques années on a confondu ce
principe quitter celui qui fonde et
l'unité de la gauche précédemment avec
l'idée que pour avoir une gauche unie il
fallait qu'on passe des accords dès le
premier tour non c'est une erreur
stratégique politique et historique donc
je le dis de manière très claire ce
matin et si je suis venu ce matin à
paris a vu luxe et nas c'était pour le
dire sauf que and i'll go elle était
candidate du ps une d'effacement vous
êtes à angers derrière notre candidat de
gauche à la fée 1,7 pour cent est ce que
la stratégie du ps seul ça marche mais
la stratégie du ps seul c'est une
stratégie qui depuis cinq ans a consisté
à jouer l'effacement anne hidalgo a
participé à cette stratégie la preuve
c'est que quand il a fallu avoir une
tête de liste ou une tête de liste aux
européennes dans la choisi monsieur
tucson pour s'effacer considérant que le
quinquennat de hollande était impossible
à assumer et qu'il fallait donc
s'effacer derrière
mycologie place publique c'est ce qui
s'est passé rappelez vous il ya deux ans
à blois le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste disait pourquoi pas un
socialiste ou un écologiste pour la
présidentielle
et puis tout ça a fini par être noyé
dans une candidature daddy d'allemands
qui elle-même au début de sa campagne se
présente comme écologiste et à la fin
comme socialiste toutes ces stratégies
qui n'a pas été justement d'affirmer une
ligne politique une stratégie de projet
politique a conduit les électeurs à les
choisir ceux qui s'affirment et ça me
paraît tout à fait logique problème non
c'est vrai le plus large mais anne
hidalgo il y a participé et anne hidalgo
y a rajouté des erreurs stratégiques
commencé comme écologiste commencé avec
le doublement je l'avais dit ici
d'ailleurs on ne fait pas on lancera une
campagne présidentielle avec une mesures
catégorielles parce que les autres
catégories qu'est ce qu'on leur dit je
suis dit tout ça je les dis j'ai été
très silencieux pendant la campagne ce
que j'ai respecté le fait que après le
vote c'était un distinguo enfin
maintenant il est temps et donc moi sa
vitre et tous ceux qui veulent réfléchir
à tout ça le 16 juillet je verrai
regardez le lieu mais le 16 juillet je
ferai un rendez vous politique à la fois
pour analyser toute cette séquence toute
cette séquence et en même temps pour
commencer à poser des bases de la
manière dont on doit répondre à la
question démocratique qu'est posée parce
que avec emmanuel macron cette fois ci
on a encore sauvé la république la clé
de voûte présidentielle tient le risque
quand on rejoint emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui c'est que le coup d'après
parce que c'est le dernier mandat d'
emmanuel macron le coup d'après c'est
que là on ne puisse pas empêché une
radicalité de s'installer à l'alternance
ne se ferait que dans les extrêmes au
fur et à mesure que vous avez pour
principe de dire c'est avec moi vous
venez pour gouverner
sous-entendu jacques avec moi qu'on peut
gouverner vous renvoyez les oppositions
alors qu'il ya besoin d'opposition mais
des besoins d'opposition qui soit à la
fois des alternatives mais qui soit
capable de porter une alternance
politique c'est ça qui fait la
démocratie et ça c'est un vrai sujet qui
dans le débat actuel doit être posée
comme je le pose juste très rapidement
vous jouez rétrospectivement vous
regrettez de ne pas avoir été le
candidat moi je viens surtout ne pas
avoir pu que c'est ça qui m'a frappé
d'avoir été complètement écartée pas
entendu j'ai écrit un livre j'ai posé
j'ai pas fais simplement de dire j'ai
envie d'être candidat j'ai dit qu'elles
étaient les risques qu'il y avait à
suivre cette dite politique j'ai annoncé
malheureusement pour moi pas au niveau
d'ailleurs où je pensais mais une
défaite puisque cette chronique de la
défaite annoncée elle commence dès des
européennes de 2019 des européennes de
2009 après le congrès d'aubervilliers
vous allez savoir plus pour imposer mais
je trouvais mon et battu serait j'ai
essayé c'était perdu d'avancé a je pense
que c'était perdu d'avancé puisque ces
espèces de mécanique de l'effacement
cette espèce d'idée que après on se
retrouve derrière signé à hidalgo je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
avant l'été cemil grand élu qui signe
pour à diego sans même avoir une
discussion sur quelle va être la
position et le programme daniel go y
avait une espèce de de sauve-qui-peut
d'espèces des 10 dès qu' il fallait se
raccrocher à quelque chose la maire de
paris étant la maire de paris eh bien
c'était la solution plus personne ne
pensait à quel projet quelle ligne
d'apparaître
au lycée fort peu aujourd'hui rester à
la tête jamais moi je vais raconter
simplement deux histoires pour que
chacun comprenne bien quand michel
rocard fait quatorze élus % aux
européennes
de
1994 il démissionne quand lionel jospin
échoue il assume la part de
responsabilité claire aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que personne n'assume
aucune responsabilité et on est déjà
reparti dans on va se ranger derrière
jean-luc mélenchon et à prendre ses
responsabilités et ne demandent pas
démissionner sais pas je suis pas là
pour aller dire faut démissionner je
suis dis simplement mais je le dis si
démissionnerait cessa gullit en
politique à un moment où on assume ses
responsabilités et une négation pas mais
écoutez voilà je fais le constat comme
vous et moi je ne demande aucune
démission chacun assume ses
responsabilités vous nous passez y voit
la responsabilité de chacun des
responsabilités que le fonctionnement du
parti est-ce qu'il faut revoir tout le
fonctionnement du parti est ce qu'il
faut là où il a changé ce parti et
moitié ou pas ce mardi le profil y voilà
il faut revoir complètement on est
arrivés à la fin d'un processus la fin
d'un cycle sic a commencé très tôt un je
pense qu'ils commencent en 2002 avec
l'échec de 2002 la manière dont on n'a
pas su comprends ce qu'ils étaient en
train de se passer à la fois sur la
montée du front national
la manière dont on devait traiter les
questions on a gagné après parce que il
ya eu un report d'une partie de la
gauche qui n'étaient pas venus voter
2004 vous en souvenez européennes
régionales régionales européennes et
puis on est reparti et chaque sur le
traité constitutionnel
ensuite victoire en 2012 devise des
échecs en 2007 victoire en 2012 mais on
n'a pas traité la question qui s'est
cristallisée entre les frondeurs au
moment où on arrive au gouvernement et
puis
le gouvernement et en particulier alors
exacerbée par l'attitude de manuel valls
qui va attiser ce clivage résultats qui
a gagné la fronde aujourd'hui qui est le
frondeur en chef c'est jean luc
mélenchon il a réussi la preuve c'est
que arnaud montebourg rejoint jolie
version on arrive à la fin de ce cycle
de qu'il est temps maintenant de se
poser les bonnes questions pour en
reconstruire un nouveau et de changer le
nom du parti au sein c'est alors la
changer le nom du parti s'il s'agit de
cette seule question et ça résonne sa
résolveur est ou non c'est d'abord
changer la manière dont on aborde des
sujets et rebâtir un projet et un pro
qui pour vous c'est qui qui pour rebâtir
le parti pour l'accident nous placer moi
je pense que ceux qui peuvent venir
travailler et j'invite le 16 juillet
alors justement il va étudier avec tous
et moi je suis prêt à discuter avec tout
le monde mais il faudrait surtout pas
commencer par se dire qu'il faut
commencer par se dire comment on va
faire pourquoi on a échoué qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait refaire et ensuite très
vite y aura un consensus ou pas
d'ailleurs et après un vote ou pas dans
une forme qui doit être complètement
différente de celle d'un congrès du
parti socialiste tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui est bien et puis on
repartira forme le 16 juillet puisque
vous nous annoncez ce matin set initial
aura quelle forme quelle forme un débat
d' analyse sur les causes de l'échec et
je contribuerai par un texte à cette
analyse et deuxièmement qu'est la
société fragmentée fracture et qu'on a
aujourd'hui quelles sont les politiques
publiques qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre par pas mesure par mesure mais
quel grand enjeu pour arriver à
ressouder une partie de cette france qui
est en train de se fragmenter la fameuse
archipel de monsieur fourquet il s'agit
d'éviter que la dérive des continents
continue ou fade et petit archipel faut
aussi que elle se rapproche ça c'est des
enjeux majeurs avec quelles politiques
publiques ça c'est des enjeux donc on
voit la social démocratie n est pas mal
mais la social démocratie elle serait
morte je me dirais que à l'échelle
européenne et disparaîtrait c'est pas le
cas et pourquoi parce que la démocratie
représentative
l' équilibre dans la démocratie
représentative sa porte aussi des
projets et ça garantit une stabilité qui
peut être porteuses d'espoir c'est ça le
sujet le 16 juillet vous invite écrit
stéphane le foll est ce que par exemple
carole delga oui bien sûr aucun dégât
sur le avec laquelle par exemple j'ai
été en désaccord puisque elle était dans
l'équipe d'olivier fort mais qui sur la
ligne politique en particulier vis-à-vis
de la france insoumise quand elle a été
candidat a été très clair depuis busnes
départ dès le départ pas parce que faut
être contre un sou mais je répète jean
luc mélenchon a une cohérence il a
affirmé un projet mais si on dit on veut
gouverner avec jean luc mélenchon faut
regarder le projet demandez le programme
et quand on demande le programme je dis
simplement automne j'ai donné plusieurs
exemples je rappelle simplement celui
des régions même les régions devraient
être dessiné en fonction des bassins
versants puisque c'est l'eau qui
deviendrait la première compétence
régionale ce que vous pourriez reprendre
le parti avec carole daigger par exemple
moi je jouerai à discuter mais prêts au
premier je suis on va pas franchir des
étapes qui ne sont pas encore franchi va
l'avoir essayé de réfléchir un tout
petit peu à la manière dont on peut se
converger en termes politiques sur le
fond mais après tout est ouvert moi je
n'ai alors là aucun sujet personnel
aujourd'hui c'est une discussion
collective qu'il faut est ce que
françois hollande est invité à sa suite
bernard cazeneuve françois lens il vous
souhaite veut dire peut venir bien
entendu parce que sur la reconstruction
de partir il faut le reconstruire avec
lui moi je pense qu'il faut reconstruire
en évitant de rester sûr il faut qu'en
virage effacé quinquennat de hollande
parce que je croyais d'ailleurs les
insoumis qui le disait si c'est la seule
raison de se rassembler ça n'a aucun
sens aucun sens maintenant un président
de la république un ancien président de
la république a toujours un mot à dire
sur la manière dont on doit envisager
l'avenir d'un pays du pays qui l'a
d'ailleurs gouverner en même temps j'ai
toujours dit les échecs l'échec du
quinquennat françois hollande c'est que
il n'a pas plus se représenter petit
s'est passé quand même quelque chose et
qui on n'est pas capable aussi de dire
ce qu a été des échecs et les erreurs on
n'avancera pas mais tout le monde doit
être invité et essayer de reconstruire
en tout cas quelque chose de totalement
différent de ce qui a été fait depuis
cinq ans et qui nous a conduits là où
nous sommes dernière question challenge
votre liste d'invités du 16 juillet ce
que vous inviterez vos voisines les
maires de rennes et de nantes alors les
mères d'aujourd'hui la maire de rennes
par exemple annonce qu'elle est pour à
l'accord avec la france est soumise je
lui pose la question et les présidentes
de la métropole posez lui la question
est ce qu'elle est d'accord et johanna
rolland maire de ris un pareil
directrice de campagne d'un hidalgo
qu'est ce qu'elle souhaite c'est quoi
leur projet c'est quoi la france
qu'elles veulent et répété à longueur de
journée comme j'entendais tout à l'heure
ça va partir des territoires non il ya
les territoires et moi je suis pour un
acte iii de la décentralisation
fondamentalement contre la planification
écologique pour une décentralisation de
la transition énergétique voilà mais à
partir de là on débat sur le fond on
essaye de porter quelque chose c'est pas
simplement d'ajouter des petits bouts
par tous et merci stéphane le foll merci
à vous d'être venu nous annoncer cette
initiative qu'on suivra bien évidemment
donc le 16 juillet on regarde à une
nouvelle france pouvoir d'achat santé
l'impatience des français c'est à la une
de votre journal merci stéphane le foll
[Musique]